A lot of traders are familiar with the
opening range breakout. You buy or sell
the breakout of the first 15 minutes of
the cash session. This strategy
published in the 1990 by Toby Crabel
proven to be one of the most consistent
edge over the last decade with a
positive profit factor and an amazing
sharp ratio. It's one of my favorite
because it's really easy to trade and
you can pair it with orderflow
confirmation to boost its edge. In this
video, I will show you how to put this
edge on steroids by using two main
things. The first one it's an orderflow
trigger and the second one it's deep
statistical analysis. and how I work
with the deep charts team to build a
model that shows you one the highest
probable excursion to give you a level
where you put your first take profit and
second one the best imbalance or
aggression to put your entry. If you
like this video subscribe to the channel
and put a like and if you want to access
the IVB model go on deeparts.com.
So in this video we are going to
understand how the opening range
breakout or initial balance breakout
works and how we can improve it. Now the
logic behind the opening range breakout
or initial balance is the following. The
New York session is the session that
hold the maximum amount of volume for
the day. So you have the strongest
battle between buyers and sellers. You
have the peak of interest and input of
volume during the day and usually you
see this as soon as the London session
open with big swings and a big battle
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers. This situation here define a
clear range and from this range you can
see rejection you can see absorption of
the buyers of the sellers exhaustion. So
you can do a lot of analysis with
volume. But the orb method works this
way. You have two defined levels that
are the top and the bottom of the range
of the first 15, 30 or 60 minutes. It
depends how you want to use it. If you
want to use it more scalp or more
intraday bias and what the model says is
that the first one that break is telling
you what is telling you who won the
battle of the most important time of the
day. So the first 15 minutes of New York
opening or 30. Okay. And from a
statistical point of view, this one have
a strong value in predicting the
direction for the day at least till
certain level that you can use as high
probability profit target. Now when we
understand this, we understand that what
we are doing is aligning with the
biggest market participants that won the
battle. So we are protected by a wall of
balance. We are going in a condition of
imbalance and we are in the direction of
the volume. Okay. Now this one used the
loan without any other confirmation have
value. Okay. Have value. This one is
using the first 15 minutes of the
session without implementing volume. So
you can already see that compared with
the S&P 500 buy and provide a smoother
equity line with less draw down and
gives you a expectancy or profit factor
that is positive. Okay. Now why this
gets interesting because during the
years I was trying to understand how to
take a model that it's already
profitable and putting it on steroids
and my kind of steroids it's orderflow.
So what I'm doing now is using the
statistical reliability of a profitable
model paired with the steroids of
orderflow analysis to get better entry
point and better riskto-reward. Okay,
how can we do this? We can do this in
multiple way. The first way is by
implementing in the model the volume
profile. Okay, let's see the model one
of IVB. So the model one of IVB is using
the following. We have point A and we
have point B. How can we define this
point A and point B? This is the opening
of the New York. We have a top. We have
a bottom on the first 15 to 30 minutes.
Okay. This is our point A and this is
our point B and the price is inside this
value for 15 30 depends on what you
prefer to use. Okay. Now we take this
top, we drag down with the fixed profile
to this level. Why this gets
interesting? Because now we not only
have price but we have the volume
distribution of the most important
interaction of the day. And we can
notice that the major point of control
so the PC so the level where the
majority of volume of the market
participant it's here. Okay, this takes
the name of PC. Now this is really
powerful because when we go from a
balance situation inside to an out of
balance. So the price accept this value.
Now the most sensitive level after you
have this is the level contained between
the value area and the PC. This is our
real block of orders. This is where when
you retrace you can expect buyers to
reload. Okay. So this is a really
sensitive confirmation from the volume
profile. So we have a profitable model
plus the volume profile framing. Okay.
And this is for location. This is
letting you understand the direction and
letting you understand also the
potential location of the area, the
sensitive area. Why this is interesting?
Because first of all, you have a more
precise entry point so you can boost
your risk to reward. And second of all,
you also have a level of invalidation if
broken. So you have a value area low
that if it gets broken, so the market
accept it, it's an invalidation point.
Okay, you don't need to wait till here.
You don't need to wait till here. You
don't need to wait till here. If we
close a candle here, okay, the setup is
invalidated. So our real risk-to-reward
is this from here to the first
protection point. And the first
protection point can be for example
here. Okay. So now our risk-to-reward is
not one to one like the test that we did
but maybe it's 1 to2 one to 2.5. So we
are using the same model with the same
directional frame and probability but
paired with order flow to improve his
matrix. This is the model one. Okay. And
this one don't use anything complicated.
Then the model two of IVB is using
orderflow. Okay. This is a little bit
more advanced. Okay. because it's using
the confirmation after the breakout.
Okay, so we have a range, we have a
point A, we have a point B, we have our
profile. Okay, we have the value area
low, we have the PC, sorry, the value
area high, the P, and we have the value
area low. And we have our framing area
to seek buy. Okay, we have a breakout,
we have the market retracing, and now we
can start using the confirmation of
order flow. Okay, what do I mean that we
can start to see how orders interact
this level? Maybe we have a lot of
aggressive sellers here with zero
result. This means that there is a big
absorption on this level on the PC.
Okay, so we can use this as a
confirmation trigger to go long or maybe
you can see an exhaustion. So you can
see that the sellers don't interact. We
have aggressive buyers with momentum at
the top and you can take a momentum
trade with a really tight stop-loss to
go to the protection level. You can use
all the confirmation of order flow not
only to have direction.1 location 2 and
confirmation of order flow.3. This is
how I built during the years the basis
and the foundation of the IVB model.
Then the team of deep charts step in and
says okay let's do deep statistical
analysis. Okay let's go through years
and years of data and use an algorithm
using neural network machine learning or
digging into the data to see what's the
highest probability point that the
market reach when you have a breakout of
the initial balance or orb. Okay. And
what the IVB does is that when you have
a breakout, okay, it plot for you the
high probability profit target, okay,
and the potential TP2. So you know that
with 65 to 70% probability, you go here
and you know that with another lower
probability, of course, you go to the
TP2. Okay? So now you have this logic
done for you by an algo. You have this
logic done for you by an algo. Okay. And
you can concentrate all your skills on
the location and on the order flow
confirmation. Okay. So the statistical
analysis is doing 50% of your work by
removing all the analysis of where you
should go the direction the analysis and
stuff is giving you an edge in direction
and in location. and point 2 and three
can add more value because you are more
precise and you have a better entry area
and confirmation than the simple orb
model. Okay. And this one it's paired
with a data analysis on the deep charts
platform that is giving you the summary
of the distribution between
consolidation session and directional.
Okay. So when you have this you can also
understand that the opposite is true. So
if you are inside this level okay you
have the opportunity to fade the top and
the bottom using a mean reverting okay
because you know that till the market
don't break completely this level the
direction is not clear so you can also
use a mean reverting model that is
spotting the absorption of the sellers
of the buyers the exhaustion on
sensitive areas that are the top and the
bottom of the range to take some mean
reverting trades okay with high
probability ility and then maybe use
this profit to get trend following when
you have enough confirmation that the
market decided where to go. And this is
what we built with the deep charts team.
Now let's go to the platform and I show
you how this works in action. Okay, now
we are in the back testing mode of deep
charts. We have a clean defined IVB top
and bottom and we are waiting for the
first 30 minutes of the session to be
completed to define clearly the areas
where we see breakout. We have a
statistical edge that the price will
continue in that direction. I will speed
up for you a little bit. Let's see how
it goes. You can see the aggression of
the sellers. On the same template I have
also the big orders. So as you can see
till the 30 minutes is completed they
continue to upload the IVB range. So we
have clear defined area. Okay we are in
the deep charts back testing system. We
have a clear defined IVB top and IVB
bottom. We have the balance area and we
have the deep trade model to see the
absorption and the aggression and the
imbalance. Okay. And we can see that the
pressure is building on the upside. So
if we have a breakout now, this is the
first 30 minutes of the session, we will
have a protection level that is the
highest probability target for the day.
Let's see how it goes. As you can see,
the sellers are getting absorbed here.
Can go up a little bit. See the buyers
continuing to step in without the
support of the aggressive orders. Can
zoom out for you a little bit inside. We
have the aggression of the buyers with
the big trades on top and we have the
imbalance. But as you can see the result
is not following up the aggression. So
probably we go a little bit in a
retracement. I go faster in the back
testing model. As you can see now it's
getting something interesting. They
rejected perfectly from the top of the
IVB. This is letting you understand how
much is sensitive this area and why if
we don't break out usually the price
stays in a range. Okay. Now what you can
see here a lot of absorption aggression
and you can see that they are trying to
break it again. Let's see how it goes.
Okay, we have a first candle breakout
and now the algorithm understand the
protection level. This is the highest
probability target for the single
session. Let's go on this one. You can
see that from this level you have an
absorption of the sellers. Really clear.
You have a lock in and confirmation from
the buyers from here. this aggression
and they come inside to reload in the
same area. Now look here what you can
see. You can see that on the testing
level they insisted again and they got
absorbed more and more. Okay? And they
are building pressure. So you have a
huge absorption on this horizontal
level. We have a clean direction. We
have a clean breakout and we are heading
to the protection level that is the most
sensitive level from a statistical point
of view. I can go faster for you to see
this in a speed up mode. See how they
are building the auction on the upside.
They are building the momentum for the
session. A little bit of retracement.
You can see that every time, see how
much is sensitive the initial balance
breakout area. Okay. Every time they
come to test this area back, they have
interaction of the aggressive market
participants. Okay. They are trying to
go up to the protection level.
aggression from the buyers. Again,
consider this guys. It's a really big
really big risk-to-reward. If you know
how to use orderflow and you try to
manage to take this entry or the test
entry, you are already 1 2 3 1 to four.
But you know that if you wants to keep a
runner when taking it out, the most
sensitive area for the day is the
protection level. Okay, this is the
highest probability target for the day.
I took a choppy session. As you can see
now they are facing the previous
imbalance cluster of the buyers and they
are pushing into it. So they are trying
to break and you can see that every time
they manage to go close to the initial
balance area that got broken. You can
see this catalyst on the upside momentum
of the aggressive buyers that is pushing
really strong on the upside. Again you
see they reached again this absorption
area and this one is really convenient
because you have the power of order flow
paired with the directional
predictability of the system that is
based on statistics. So you are not
using discretionality to frame your bias
for the day. See how much this one I
took the choppy session to make you
understand that even in days where you
don't have a directional day still
giving you an amazing edge when you
break out. Imagine how many trades you
would have been able to take in this
area again to the same absorption area
for the fourth time. Gone a little bit.
Now we are going late in the session.
I'm showing you all of this because I
want to show you how the market feel the
area of the IVB also on the long term.
Okay. So look at this. This is the
breakout level. Okay. And we had a
choppy day. So I took one of the worst
session to do this. But look how the
market reacted to this level. Okay. So
we frame this area in the beginning. We
have an amazing absorption here. They
came back the day after. Okay. And they
had this kind of reaction. Why? Because
this is the accumulation area of the
cash session and the model is spotting
this with the most sensitive level. And
you can scalp in the middle all this
execution. Let's go to another day.
Let's go to the next one. The 27. Let's
reset. I show also how the model is
built before the session. So we have
here the first 30 minutes that are
starting. So I show you how this is
created. Now we are not interested in
order flow because the pressure it's
unfolding and you will start to see that
they start to create the area after the
opening of New York. So let me go a
little bit further and this area last
for the first 30 minutes. Here they
start with the IVB. Okay, they start to
plot the level. Now wait for the first
30 minutes of the session. So we have a
clean defined range. The range is
expanding till you don't have the
closure of the first 30 minutes. It's a
really big range. This session still not
closed. We are 15 minutes into the
session. You see they still expand the
IVB because the session is still
unfolding. 3 minutes and it's closed.
Okay. Now if they break this level
because the range is defined. Okay. Look
how much aggression then the protection
level will appear somewhere here. the
algo will plot it for us. Okay, you see
it's plotted the protection level and
it's plotted also the maximum extreme
average. So when you have a really
directional session this is a huge
risk-to-reward but the probability of
course is lower. Let me show you how
this work in real time. As you can see
the sellers are trying to push it down
but the buyers have a clear direction
and you start to plot all kind of
imbalance in the middle. Okay. So as you
can see on the level you see that the
sellers are trying their best to push
and you have a lot of absorption on this
horizontal level but when they break
this one they have a drift. Okay they
have a drift on the upside direction. So
what this means is that usually you see
a breakout, you see a retracement and
then you see the real battle beginning
between buyers and sellers and from this
interaction you can see that the sellers
got absorbed on multiple cluster but the
buyers are still managing to push above
the IVB and when they push above the IVB
they have a drift okay because you have
to consider that they won the first
battle of the day that is the most
important one because it's the cash
session battle and they defined in the
direction for the day. So everything you
take either you prefer to take
absorption on the test of an imbalance
or you prefer to take a potential reload
on the level if they manage to reach it
again. You have multiple trades that you
can execute with the confirmation of
where the price will most likely extend
with the biggest probability. So you can
say okay I'm done for the day and then
consider that in some directional
session that the first two ones that we
saw so the one of Monday and this one
that we are seeing it's not the best
directional session okay because you
have a really compressed price after the
breakout but it's letting you understand
that it's really powerful at defining
the direction and I'm keeping on the
chart also all this executed order
because it's giving you a proxy for who
is winning the battle. For example, in
this interaction, you can see a lot of
rewarded buyers and a lot of absorbed
sellers. What does it mean? The buyers
want this interaction here. Here, what
you can see that the sellers are
actually managing to have more results.
Why? Because the buyers are absorbed and
the sellers are having results. In this
case, what we see the buyers are
actually trying to push the auction up
and they are winning this battle. Okay.
So, what we can expect? We can expect
from the orderflow perspective that this
can be an interesting reload level of
the buyers. And how can we have a
confirmation when you have a breakout of
this horizontal level? Okay, because
this is the level where the real fight
between buyers and seller is happening.
They reach the discount one that is all
this area and they are loading again.
Okay, this is the high risk-to-reward
trade if you want to take it. Okay. So
when you have aggression of the buyers
for example here okay they are
protecting the area you can consider a
buy with a stop loss below that goes to
the protection level. Now not all the
session will give you this amazing
setups but when you know what you are
watching in terms of order flow. So you
have a allocation and you have a
confirmation you can frame this
opportunity by using the win of the
battle of the buyers. Okay. and the
momentum that it's directly derived from
this interaction. Let's go a little bit
faster. Can see the sellers are still
super aggressive on this one. They
tested again the entry level and they
are playing around. Okay, now let's go
to the replay of another session. You
can see that the IV bits unfolding. Now
we need to wait for 30 minutes for it to
be defined. You can see all these
absorption of the sellers. Okay, on this
level then you can see a huge aggression
of the sellers. So if they will break on
the downside, we will consider short. If
they break on the upside, we will
consider long. As of now, the buyers are
really aggressive on the upside. But
still, we are only 15 minutes into the
session. So let's see who is managing to
break out either the high or the low.
And from this moment, you will see
either the protection level appear on
the top or on the bottom side. They are
managing to do still 5 minutes to finish
the first 30 minutes of interaction. So
the IVB is updating to the actual volume
and price interaction. Little bit of
absorption at the top. Okay, they
managed to break. What is this? This is
the protection level. Okay, the
protection level is the most sensitive
areas to reach if we go buy and then we
have the extended average. And you know
what I will do? I will just remove the
order flow from this one because I want
to show you also the power of the
profile. Okay, remove everything. Just
keep the imbalance to show you who is
dominating this situation. I will mark
the top of the IVB and I will give a
projection of the profile on this one.
So you can see what you can see that on
this interaction we have the major
volume concentration here. Okay. So what
can we expect? We can expect that the
price will break and reload. Break and
reload. Break and reload. Okay. All this
accumulation area it's also sustained by
this amazing imbalance. Okay, they
already show you an absorption of the
sellers. So we have all the confirmation
that this session we can play the bounce
to go up maybe 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 and
then if the market gives you and it's a
direction all day you have the run that
goes to the protection level. Now we
will go a little bit fast and let's see
how it unfolds. Okay, they managed to
reload on the level and you can see that
the price is really aggressive on the
upside and it bricks the price back to
the IVB high. Okay, and all these this
can seems to you like small entry but
all these setups have a really high
risk-to-reward when you know how to
frame the area. Okay, you have a really
high now if you manage to reach the
maximum. It's amazing but the win rate
goes low. So it's better to take 1 2 3 1
to 2.5 with a really consistent way of
executing it. Let's see how this area
react also for the long term. Let's put
a protection level cell. This one is
calculated by an algo. It's doing a lot
of analysis behind. Let me go faster so
you can enjoy. I took another session
that is choppy to make you understand
that even when the market is not moving
and is giving you a consolidation range,
you are only engaging from the most
interesting area. Okay. So if you also
have problems of overtrading or if you
don't know how to stay out of the market
when the conditions are not good. See
for example he already gave you an
amazing long here another long here and
you could have made one to two one two
one two three and then another one two
three. Okay now we are going late in the
session but I will keep the level marked
because I want to show you this was a
super consolidation session. Okay. I
want to show you how the price react
from the level that we marked. How much
they are powerful. Let's mark it on. As
you can see, it's a super compression.
Okay. They It's really compressed. They
are dancing in the area of the IVB low.
Okay. And the area of the protection
level that it's on the top. They are in
this area. They are late in the session.
The session is almost closing. Look how
they manage to react to the protection
level. Okay. Now, it's possible that you
close before that you will not hold this
position. But what I want to show you is
the power in helping you to understand
first of all the pressure, second the
location and the orderflow confirmation.